NILOFER MERCHANT: Today, any
individual has access to
information that 20 years ago,
only the richest billionaire
had access to.
Seems kind of obvious, right,
to this audience of people?
And yet, the implications for
business, and business models,
and what creates power in those
business models, it
changes everything.
So I wanted to spend a little
bit of time talking about the
business models, what changes,
what it means for us as
leaders, and what I think people
can do, especially some
of you who might be going out
and maybe starting your own
companies post Google, what I
think that means for you as
entrepreneurs.
So the gorillas of the
marketplace, the way
organizations had power, here
are some of the constructs
that they considered.
One was that being bigger than
everyone else meant that they
could have pricing power in the
marketplace, meant that
they could control which
suppliers they had access to.
It meant that they had this
thing called sustainable
competitive advantage.
Sustainable competitive
advantage has now
gone from 40 years--
long arcs--
to 12 years in old industries,
and 5 in fast moving
industries.
So it's really hard to use
that term, sustainable
competitive advantage, anymore
because it doesn't mean the
same thing.
Any advantage that an old
organization had when they
tried to build up a moat around
their business actually
doesn't hold true.
And in fact, the first chapter
of "Social Era" starts with an
obituary to this character,
traditional strategy.
And I, basically, say it was
good while we had you.
You had a good life.
But you're dead now.
And we ought to honor the
rules of a new era.
But gorillas, these big
organizations, are actually
facing all the changes in the
marketplace, whether it was
crowd sourcing, or SaaS plays,
or the things that
fundamentally lowered the cost
structure of having an
organization.
And they're looking at it and
thinking to themselves, all
this is really causing me to
have to compete against a much
leaner organization.
And so it's almost like they sit
there and they think, how
do I go on a diet?
But they're missing the
fundamental construct that
something so big and
shifted that it's
not just about Spandex--
sorry for such a girl
reference there.
Women wear these things
called Spanx.
Any of you have ever
heard of Spanx?
Men also have them.
But I'd be really scared if one
of you guys admitted that
you wore Spanx.
Apparently Roger Moore in the
James Bond movies, because he
wasn't in good shape,
actually wore Spanx.
That was the early generation
of Spanx.
There you go.
Trivia.
So big organizations are
often thinking--
seeing all these things and
seeing that they're performing
against these lighter based
companies-- and thinking, I've
just got to figure out how
to do more with less.
And I think that's actually
a false architecture.
Instead I think there's
something
entirely new coming on.
And I call that thing
the social era.
And as I talk about social, most
people finish the word
social with the word media.
So I just want to slow down and
say, for me, social is not
about media.
It's not a marketing or
communications thing.
And in fact, it might just be
helpful to kind of make some
distinctions about other key
terms that people have used.
So social media, obviously,
was created around the
Cluetrain Manifesto.
It's done a great thing
in the world.
It's like the Red Bull
of organizations.
Makes you maybe go faster,
accelerate communications, and
the speed of communications.
So it is like Red Bull
in that way.
But it's still just about
communications and creating a
dialogue versus a monologue.
Enterprise 2.0.
How many of you guys have
heard that term?
Oh, not so much this group.
So Enterprise 2.0 was coined
by Andrew McAfee
about six years ago.
And the idea was that the
tools would allow
organizations to function
differently.
Peter Kim actually came up
with this idea of social
business and actually kind
of stole the term
from Muhammad Yunus.
Muhammad Yunus said, social
business we can actually care
about meaning and work.
And Peter Kim came along and
said-- and he was working at
Dachis Group at the time, which
is a marketing agency--
said, you know what?
What if we could actually use
these tools to actually create
wealth and exchange across all
the players, so not just
shareholders but customers,
community.
So thinking about it that way.
But he fundamentally didn't
challenge whether or not an
organization was still needed.
And so in "Social Era," I'm
basically saying two things.
One is, just as a comparison
point, in the industrial era
when oil, and capital,
land, limited
resources were at play.
Then what you needed was
an organization that
could create scale.
And value was fundamentally
about what an organization
could do and you had to belong
within the walls of that
organization to create value.
"Social Era," it's exactly
the opposite.
It starts with a single,
connected human.
Whether or not you belong to an
organization, or work for
an organization, pretty much
a secondary effect.
And so what that changes is
why are we all together?
And if there's all those people
out there who could be
creating value with us,
how do we engage that?
So that's the institutional
view.
And then, at an individual
level, it changes because we
get to start thinking about
ourselves not just am I an
employee of such and such?
But what is this unit of value
creation that I bring?
And where do I want to
plug that unit--
such a mechanical term--
into?
If I'm a LEGO block, what other
LEGO blocks do I want to
go join with so I can
start creating value
and build from there?
The shift changes how we think
about leadership, how we think
about business models, how we
think about even just when we
think about scaling.
What is scaling?
So I'll give you a couple
examples of how
that comes to play.
Singularity University, how
many of you guys know
Singularity because it's
here in the Valley?
There you go.
Big group.
Aimed at people who have
already gotten graduate
degrees but who fundamentally
want to change the world.
And their idea was instead
of teaching people
backward-looking information,
let's teach them
forward-looking information
because if they're going to be
true change agents in the
world, they need that.
But that changes really often.
What is new and current three
years ago is not as new and
current today.
And so you have to build an
organizational construct that
is fundamentally designed for
speed for that kind of
flexibility.
So they deliver almost 400 hours
of curriculum with seven
full-time staff.
That seven full-time staff
basically hold the mission of
the organization.
And then they recruit
the next group.
The next group, that sort of
10 thought leaders across
robotics, and biomedical stuff,
and so on, tissue
engineering, really innovative
stuff, that 10 people then go
find the next 20 people who are
the leaders in the field.
20 people can happen
from anywhere.
So inherently global, inherently
social, using
collaborative technologies to
bring them all together.
No one needs to be in one
particular place.
They come in.
They deliver their
piece of value.
They leave again.
At the end of every semester,
it collapses all back down.
So you sit there, and you go,
what do we need to actually
deliver next semester?
Change is built into the
organizational design.
Change is built into how they
even think about things.
So it's not how do we protect
and maintain tenured staff, or
these buildings, right?
But what is it we really want
to be called to do?
And then what is the way in
which we'll modularly figure
out who needs to belong
as part of our tribe?
Those people certainly are
affiliated with Singularity
University in the sense that
some of the best leaders in
the world come and
teach there.
They don't work for
that institution.
And the institution gets to get
value from that exchange.
TED.
Probably everyone in this group
has watched a TED video.
Yes?
So TED actually started out as
a really elite conference--
originally one, now two--
where just a couple, maybe
like 1,000, people
participated.
And as those people came
together, they would come and
they'd be influential
and stuff.
But then they'd leave.
And four years ago or so they
said, you know, maybe we
should share the talks
that are happening.
We should share them online.
So they started doing something
with YouTube to
share videos as they were
being created by the
conference, which upped the
production level and focused
all that, which is good.
Sharing free, good.
But the thing that really made
TED more powerful is they
figured out there were actually
some people that
might want to create TED
conferences, too.
TEDxes.
And so they created this
little sub-brand.
And to hear them tell the story
is they thought maybe
five, maybe 10 people might be
interested in doing these
things because, of course, it
will take a lot of work.
You have to curate
all the speakers.
You have to be really attentive
to holding an event.
There's just a ton of
details to manage.
So five, maybe 10.
Since then, three years later,
5,000 events have happened
around the world.
22,000 hours of content has been
created in the process.
And about 220 of those talks
have been posted on ted.com.
So TED has figured out
how to create scale.
Ted.com being incredibly
exclusive.
Very, very small staff
of people curate
what goes on ted.com.
Ted conferences being semi open
in that you have to apply
and be relatively
rich to get in.
And then TEDx open to all people
who want to both create
the event as well as people who
want to attend an event.
Scale.
If you tried to do that
with a budget--
just think about a traditional
organization like GE or I
don't know, Xerox.
The idea of TEDx just
kind of would--
they're baffled by it because
they think we should do it.
And so scale for them is much
more about we hire the people,
we have the buildings,
we have the staff.
So that's the gorilla
mentality.
And of course, the
opposite is TEDx.
It's gazelles.
It's how 800 unique parties
are getting together and
figuring out how to
create value.
And of course, since TEDx has
started, they've had all these
beautiful events all
over the earth.
Brene Brown is the speaker
in the middle.
And she now has 10 million views
on a talk she gave at
TEDx Houston.
These really flexible constructs
can apply to every
part of a business.
And for most traditional
organizations, they actually
don't see that.
So that's one of the reasons
I created this table.
But in HR, the Singularity
University example shows that
you don't have to have employees
creating value.
In service, it used to be that
you used to have call centers.
And those people worked for
you even if they were
outsourced to a different
country.
And McAfee mavens, or Intuit
accountants, are two examples
where communities of people
actually provide
peer to peer support.
Intuit accountants now
answer 74% of all the
questions peer to peer.
And the staff has really
gotten the
chance to step back.
But what's more interesting,
right, is that the community
of people is actually adding
value on to that platform.
Capitalization.
Everyone in this room has
probably heard about
Kickstarter and all the various
ways in which you can
fund something.
But people aren't just
getting money.
They're actually showing an
investment in the person.
It's a community.
And the way they're putting $1
into that system actually
changes how committed they
are to that act.
I just invested in Everpurse.
So it charges a phone up.
Woman, entrepreneur.
Women get less than 3% of
all venture fundings.
And so her chance of getting
access to capital on her own,
pretty low just if you think
about the stats on that.
But here she is.
She went out to the community.
She figured out how to change
the phone charging process.
So if you're out for a
day, your phone will
almost always run out.
But this purse, as you put the
phone back in the purse
actually charges the purse.
You have a secondary recharge
unit basically available to
you at all times.
Worth investing in
because it's just
such a creative idea.
And of course, now
has raised--
I think she's up
to $2 million.
And the product's going
into production.
Product used to be about
we make it once and
sell it many times.
And all the examples online are
about, whether it's Etsy
or gosh, what's the
t-shirt company?
Threadless, which I remember a
couple of years ago, I was
obsessed with.
All different ways in which we
can create custom production.
Desktop Factory, which
actually allows
you to do 3D printing.
I love it.
Somebody sent in a
picture of a dog.
And they built a little
miniature dog.
And I'm like, how interesting.
One day, you could actually
build like a
real big sized dog.
But there are just so many ways
in which the product is
not a product, it's
our product.
It's a thing we care about
so much that the value
proposition changes because it's
not just about a thing
somebody else has made.
It's about a thing we've
made together.
And when you've made
something together,
you're not selling it.
You don't have to sell the thing
you've made together.
Distribution.
Certainly Amazon to Etsy.
Tons of examples of open
marketplaces changing
distribution.
Supply chain.
How many of you guys use LEGO
Factory when they were doing
the custom stuff.
Anybody?
What did you build?
AUDIENCE: We just built more
"Star Wars" stuff.
NILOFER MERCHANT: Oh, more
OK, and what did you build?
AUDIENCE: Hubble telescope.
NILOFER MERCHANT: A
public telescope?
AUDIENCE: Hubble telescope.
NILOFER MERCHANT: Wow,
you're kidding.
AUDIENCE: It used to
be that there was a
set back in the '70s.
It was discontinued.
I'm sorry.
In the '80s, then it
was discontinued.
NILOFER MERCHANT:
There you go.
So people have sent in houses.
You can build anything.
And for a long time, people
were actually sending in
pictures of their kids because
it's really a way for you not
to just have a LEGO set.
It's to have your LEGO set.
Sales.
Sales used to be back--
I'm kind of going to date myself
when I tell the story.
But back when I was at Apple,
you used to have to sign a
contract with these people
called retailers in order for
them to carry your product.
And your job was to figure out
how to give them enough money
so they wouldn't carry anybody
else's product.
And it was all this set
of monetization plays.
And Evernote, as just one
example, gives away their
product-- gosh, where am
I standing right now--
gives away their product
knowing that
enough people use them.
You can monetize it in
many other ways.
And then, of course, we talked
about the TED to TEDx example,
which a marketing budget could
not merely do in the same way.
They've created scale.
And they've created
enthusiasm.
influencers.
Every part of the business model
is affected when you can
allow commute to actually
co-create with you.
They don't work for you.
You don't tell them
what to do.
But this stuff happens.
And in fact, when I tell this
idea to more traditional
business owners, just because
I have that background, they
will look at me like that's
just super scary.
Is it scary for any of you?
OK.
Well, no.
Apparently--
OK, how is it scary?
AUDIENCE: How do you
maintain quality?
NILOFER MERCHANT: How do
you maintain quality?
That's a great question.
Do you have one, too?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
where it's more like a social
mesh rather than
being within the brand?
NILOFER MERCHANT: Right, how
do you own the brand?
That's super scary.
In fact, I'm going to step away
from the slides for a
second and tell you
the story of TED.
So TED with its now 5,000
events, around December last
year, some people in Spain
produced a TEDx.
TEDx Valencia I think it was.
And they had people who--
I'm trying really hard not
to make fun of it--
my face is going to give
it away, though.
Plas--
oh, god, what was the word?
Plasticity.
They came up with this word
that didn't mean anything.
And then they had some person
who understood the psychic
healing power of crystals.
And they had these pretty
nonscientific people
positioning all their stuff
as scientific stuff.
And somebody ended up writing
a post who witnessed it and
said this was an offense
on so many levels.
Like it was an offense
to science.
It was an offense to the people
who had to witness it.
It was an offense to TED.
It was just an offense to-- oh,
and I think the last line
was, and to common sense
because it was just--
it was ridiculous.
So here many, many miles away
happening in a different
language and somebody on
Reddit ends up posting,
originally in the Spanish
thing, and posting it on
Reddit saying, TEDs name is
being dragged through the mud.
5,000 people comment on it.
Within 24 hours, it goes all
over Twitter and all the
logical places.
And TED starts stepping
into the fray.
And first they say, people
are allowed to
have their own stuff.
And that sometimes happens.
We'll manage it later
and yada yada.
And then what happens in this
dialogue, though, because it's
not just a one way thing is
they use it to learn.
And somebody says,
you know what?
You're not giving your people
enough guidance as to how to
pick speakers.
And so a bunch of your content
is pseudoscience crap.
In fact, there's one
that's beautiful.
If you go on Quora, and
there's somebody who's
actually posted a TED talk and
says, how long can you get
through this talk without
wanting to throw up?
And it's a physicist over at
Stanford that says not long
and just debunks the talk.
That talk has since
been removed.
The thing that TED had to do was
to step into the dialogue
and figure out what is
it they could learn.
And then, they actually ended
up posting a multi-page kind
of process.
Like people, we gotta
fix this.
And this is not our
problem, TED.
This is our problem, TED.
And they actually asked
the community to
step into the framework.
Like step up how much
you're curating.
Step up how you're doing it.
And so, certainly, there's a
risk in all of that stuff
that's happened.
But what they actually said
is openness wins overall.
As much as we make these people
part of our co-creative
process, they are also
part of the solution.
So in the problem
is a solution.
And they ended up posting a
whole series of things and
working through that.
And I think it's just terrifying
for anyone who owns
a brand because your brand can
be drug through the mud.
And of course, there's a whole
control issue about how do you
manage quality.
And in TED's case, one of the
ways they manage quality is to
say, this section
of it is free.
1,000 flowers bloom.
And this section we highly
curate, TED.com.
And so how do you allow--
because the brand is so
indistinct to some people.
How do you do both and
make sure you're
managing your quality?
So I hope I answered both
those two concerns.
But I think it's scary on
multiple levels than just the
ones that you've mentioned.
It's when you're leading
a leaderless context,
how do you do that?
And if you went to business
school like I did, the way
we're taught leadership
is you're in charge.
And it's about how much you're
leading people or resources.
And power comes from leading
people or resources, not about
whether or not you're
leading an idea.
And that's the fundamental shift
here that we're talking
about is TED's leading an idea
and so are a whole bunch of
other organizations.
There's a question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TED is obviously a
great example.
But the reason why people want
to help TED is because TED is
a very strong brand.
NILOFER MERCHANT: Yes.
As [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: However, if I'm
starting TED, I don't think I
would get the same following.
It really has to do, once you're
already a success,
people wouldn't [INAUDIBLE] time
into helping [INAUDIBLE].
Also because in their own self
interest that they want to
become part of that success.
NILOFER MERCHANT: So you're
raising a really good point,
which is how do you get people
to run with you.
And so in TED's case, they had
enough of a magnetic pull.
But in other cases, it's
figuring out how do you have
shared interests.
So in TED's case, they're
actually doing this thing
where people who want to bring
ideas to market use the master
brand of TED and are able to
invest literally hundreds of
hours in order to do that.
The question is why are all
those people doing it?
And how do you really
tap into that?
Kickstarter has started--
it's only three years old.
It's kind of hard to imagine
that because it's had such a
profound effect.
But what it's tapping into is
this desire that's beyond
money, about how can I commit
to certain things?
And what is this shared product
I might want to bring
into this market or this shared
purpose I might have
with someone?
And that starts to create
the magnet.
And so instead of thinking
about how do I tell other
people, it's what's that
magnetic force of purpose?
And how do I get it to be so
darn strong that they'll come?
And once you tap into that,
you start tapping into a
different source, a
creative source.
It causes people to run
with you using the
visual behind me.
And that's what I'm trying to
talk to you is the shift used
to be that you used
to do stuff by
yourself, alone, apart.
And power came from the value
chain kind of process of being
distinctly apart.
And then the other one is about
community, which is how
do I get a bunch of people
to start working in
collaboration?
And that shifts scale.
But it also means that from a
marketing perspective, you're
no longer just talking
about a product.
So just take 20 years ago.
We take it for granted today.
But 20 years ago, the power of
being able to sell a product
was how big a megaphone
you could have.
And that share of voice, as it
was called in the marketplace,
allowed you to dominate how much
you could then exclude
other people.
That's not really--
not the case anymore.
So what causes people to then be
pulled into the story with
you is about purpose
and who can join
with you in that endeavor.
In the TED example, it's really
easy to see the shared
purpose is you get to create
content and ideas that matter.
But what is the shared
purpose--
let's take Google+.
Why does someone invest
in Google+
versus, let's say, Facebook?
Anybody have a take on that?
AUDIENCE: I'd say one that I
hear a lot from our users is
that there's a level of
authenticity, that they can be
contextual, that they can--
instead of putting on a
persona and sort of status
casting the glamour of their
life, they can have authentic
meaningful conversations in
the safe context of the people
that they actually want to
talk to for a given topic.
NILOFER MERCHANT: So the circles
kind of construct
allows you to actually say,
here's who I want to talk to
about this thing.
AUDIENCE: Right.
NILOFER MERCHANT: So it
creates more meaning.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NILOFER MERCHANT: Yeah.
So meaning, instead of just
broad, is what creates a
difference.
Any other thoughts on why
someone would choose Google+
over Facebook?
Why would someone go spend the
time, energy, time shifting
their protocols from Facebook?
And I just think it's
more dominant today.
So I'll just use that as
the example to Google+.
AUDIENCE: When you want to have
a personal persona, you
might want to use Facebook.
But I have a professional
persona--
so I don't think it's
an either or.
So I use Google+ as sort of
my professional persona.
And Facebook is where all
my aunts and uncles are.
NILOFER MERCHANT: Or your old
high school buddies, which I'm
sort of amazed that all these
high school buddies exist
because they didn't talk
to me in high school.
I don't understand why
they talk to me now.
If you help me manage my
presence more, then all of a
sudden, I have more
vested interest.
I think the circles thing is
profound in terms of how I
manage what I want to share.
So I am a grandma in addition to
being an author in addition
to I have a ton of questions
of things that sometimes I
don't really want to ask to
a really broad group.
I just want to ask to a really
small group because I'm
actually testing an idea.
And I want to see just
how crazy it is.
And I don't want to necessarily
broadcast it.
Sometimes I'm just really
testing an early idea.
So there's this other level
of communication that I'm
managing, which Facebook doesn't
allow me to manage.
And I could do something like
what you're suggesting, which
is I can use Facebook
for one thing and
Twitter for another thing.
But I think what's happening
is attention, which is the
currency of the social era,
is being depleted.
And as long as I'm doing
literally LinkedIn--
don't forget those guys--
LinkedIn, Facebook,
Twitter, Google+.
Oh my god, I could
spend a day.
And so I think there's something
there about what is
the purpose?
And I think as all this
attention continues to get
diverged, I think the
opportunity to come back
together and manage in one spot
is going to become more
interesting.
So I think that's going to
become especially interesting
to those of us that
are deluged.
And we'll be the ones who will
go to a new platform.
So that's just a thesis
that I have.
I could be completely wrong.
That's one of my early thesis.
But what I'm saying is if you
can figure out what's that
purpose of what problem could
you solve for someone like me
who is pretty active online, you
might actually be able to
also create a domino effect
for other people.
And it's when you start thinking
about that, you start
to change how you think
about messaging.
It's tying back to what is
the fundamental need?
And I know that's probably
incredibly obvious to this
audience, and I'm just pointing
out that it's not
obvious to a lot marketeers.
That we think first about what
is the product I have, and how
do I blast it out?
I still am kind of amazed at how
many press releases still
manage to come in my inbox even
though I keep tagging it
as spam because I'm like
really, people.
If it's important, I'll find
out about it on my own.
Don't tell me.
I don't want to know from you.
I want to know from a
different context.
So those two shifts though
change the business model
piece, which is how
we started.
So we said that 800 pound
gorilla that had power by
having power over other people,
by having a bunch of
people work for them, by locking
up capital, by locking
up resources, by having more
capital to be able to shout
that megaphone to the world,
that guy's been sitting around
thinking about-- guy, sorry.
But it is--
has been thinking about the diet
like how do I get myself
to just act leaner.
And he should be thinking
about how do I act more
gazelle like because the
architecture that they've been
using is I make a
lot of stuff.
And I sell a lot of it.
And that's how I get
to have scale.
That's how I become
successful.
That is an architecture of 1970
of a company Purina dog
chow might include.
Sorry, that's a personal
reference he said to
me a long time ago.
And those gorilla constructs
are no longer valid.
But that is largely the
constructs that are taught in
business school today.
And they are essentially
eliminating or not seeing this
other set of apertures.
So I just want to expand the
framework of how we might
think about business models
in the future.
The first is thinking about
scale not as an axis about
just the stuff I do alone and
separate but the stuff I do
with others.
That is so fundamental
a tectonic shift.
And this group might take
it for granted.
But the broader world
does not.
And business models don't
play to that.
And the second is to think
about not just what we
produce, but what is the way
in which we engage other
people in that purpose because
that changes things.
And just to kind of make it a
little bit more real, I'm
going to overlay the examples.
So of course, the quadrants
start to create meaning.
One has more about meaning,
one about communities, one
about co-creation.
But as you see the examples,
you can start to see
how that plays out.
Zipcar.
Avis did not create Zipcar.
Avis had to buy Zipcar.
Why?
Because they consider that
idea about sharing,
stewardship--
ugh.
Like that just wouldn't
occur to them.
It wasn't part of their
business model.
How do we make money as Avis.
Three years ago it was about
I have enough cars.
I have a fleet of
cars and assets.
And I have enough scale.
So I can reach all the spots
in which you need the cars.
So the idea of this
decentralized kind of
construct or actually not owning
a resource in the same
way having importance
dismissed it.
In fact, it's kind of easier to
see this example when I do
the banking one.
So Bank of America for years
missed the opportunity to
actually do any kind of
microlending, which is what
Kiva really created six,
seven years ago.
Microlending, which allows me
to give $25 but that $25
largely to be circulated an
improve the economy in
developing areas.
They actually spent $2 million
funding a company called
ProFounder, which allowed
someone like me--
if you were a local dry cleaner
and I wanted to help
you go green, I could
invest in it but
actually get paid back.
So in a traditional world of
lawyers, it costs over
$100,000 for that transaction
to happen.
And ProFounder found a way
to do it for $1,000.
Pretty incredible
business model.
Allows capital to come
from many sources.
Allows it to be paid back.
So instead of buying ProFounder,
they spent $2
million and several years of
legislation putting ProFounder
out of business.
Yeah.
I was one of the early investors
in ProFounder just
so I'm being full disclosure.
But the reason I really thought
they were important is
because I thought they let a
different kind of community
construct really
come into play.
And then of course, they skip
things like PayPal and Square
because they're like, yeah,
yeah, those little small
merchants, they're too small
for us to care about.
And we're going to charge
them more because
they're more high risk.
And yet, anyone who's gone to a
hairdresser and who's done a
Square exchange, I have more
community with that Square
exchange person than I do that
merchant at Lunardi's.
It changes the relationship.
They're actually less risky
because we know each other.
We're going to be in the same
park together later that day.
The banking industry, like any
big industry, has basically
been saying, yeah, yeah,
those other quadrants?
Yeah, yeah, they don't matter.
Community?
No, no.
So they're actually really
struggling with this.
But until we understand business
models that apply to
all four constructs, we will
not expand our universe.
We will not expand how value
creation actually happens.
I just want to double click down
on this notion of purpose
because sometimes I do
a talk like this.
People nod their head
around purpose.
And then we walk out of the
room, and it turns out we're
not defining it the same way.
So I'm just going to
take five minutes.
And then I'm going to open
up for questions on that.
Purpose is really
about the why.
But I'll give you a couple
of examples.
So how many of you guys have
gone to Sports Authority?
Notice that no one in there
actually does sports?
Noticed?
And so usually that gets a big
laugh, so I'm curious?
You guys actually think
they know sports?
So in Sports Authority, they
hire a cashier person.
Or they hire someone to do
stocking, or someone to--
but people don't actually
love the sports.
But in comparison, when
you go to REI, people
actually love the sport.
And they will literally walk you
over from a backpack area
to the map area and say, where
are you thinking about going?
Let's make sure you
get the right map.
And by the way, instead of
buying that product because
that's kind of expensive, if
this is your first time out,
you might want to rent it
because it's a lot cheaper.
They will actually get you
enthusiastic about sports.
Difference between Sports
Authority and REI.
OK.
So apparently that build
wasn't going to build.
But the difference
is about purpose.
So when you're REI, you're
actually hiring talent based
on that purpose, that passion
that that person brings in to
the organization.
And that's what allows them to
show up fully alive at work
and engage with consumers
the way they do.
So it's a way for us to actually
think about who do we
put on our team.
RIM to Apple.
So RIM many years ago and then,
of course, you guys
extend the story.
And to other audiences, by
the way, I talk about
Google quite a bit.
So I'm just avoiding
doing it here.
Why would you tell the same
story to a group that
already knows it.
RIM, three, four years ago
focused on creating the
developer app and actually
picked--
they felt like their
job was to pick--
what was the application that
should be on the device.
And then Apple came along and
said, gosh, that's costing
first of all a lot of money.
And why should we be
the ones to pick?
And they just figured out how to
change the fundamental cost
system of developing an app from
a $1 million to $10,000.
Google came along and
did it to $1,000.
1,000 flowers blooming.
Why should we pick?
And that open model--
RIM is certainly closed,
Apple is semi open,
Google fully open.
Google now has 50% of market
share of the mobile space in
less than three years.
Apple earns only 4% of its
sales from the app store.
But of course, what would be
Apple without the app store?
And of course, RIM-- you
know the demise of RIM.
So that story kind of
plays itself out.
Purpose then lets somebody own
that device and really think
about it as their device.
So the silly things I might do
with mine is going to be
different than the thing you
would do with yours and how we
all geek out on our
own device.
It personalizes it both in terms
of what we produce and
then how we actually
consume content.
And of course, it shows
up in the ways
we think about products.
Years ago, my husband drove home
with a white Prius, and I
had no idea he was going to
buy a Prius that day.
But he showed up at home,
and I'm like OK.
I'm like why?
That's not a car.
That is not a car.
That is a transportation pod.
And so I was sort of like
why would you do that?
Why would you trade a perfectly
nice BMW in for like
a thing that's not even
fun to drive?
And the thing that I didn't get
at the time was how much
my husband valued the earth
more than he valued a car.
But if you would have gone to
General Motors or any major
company, they would have
thought about a
car as having more--
the best car in the world having
better luxury seats, or
better heat, better stability
on the road.
And they would have kept
building a bigger and bigger
car, which explains
the SUV market.
Luxury.
But what they didn't account for
is the set of values that
someone can hold that actually
allows them to take trade offs
in the marketplace.
So for them, the optimal car is
not the most luxurious car.
The optimal car is the car
that is best on the
earth set of values.
GM actually caught onto that
just about recently.
But it's because they didn't
see outside their world.
They didn't have a shared
purpose with the consumer.
It was them making a product
and selling it out.
So as soon as you step into
this shared space, the
comments outside the perimeter
of your walls, you start
really creating products
quite differently.
And it becomes an alignment tool
within the enterprise and
external to the enterprise.
How you get that herd of people
to come work with you?
It's figuring out what is that
purpose that so magnetically
draws them in that they're
willing to work sometimes for
free in the TED case.
Hundreds of hours to work for
free and to come create with
you because you found something
quite appealing for
them to join in on.
So I'll take questions because
we have a moment I think.
We have a moment?
We're good?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we've
go 15 minutes.
NILOFER MERCHANT: To
take questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'll start with
the first question.
So--
NILOFER MERCHANT:
He got the mic.
How'd he do that?
Wow.
AUDIENCE: So thank you
for the presentation.
That's a really cool insight.
But the thing that was keeping
into my mind that it's a lot
of US and Western
type of insight.
So there is a billion in China,
billion in India, and
another billion in the rest of
Asia, that type of a change
will happen in the longer
and longer future.
NILOFER MERCHANT: Of
course it will.
AUDIENCE: How can we anticipate
like the starter spark?
How can we be ready as Google
and as individuals who might
go in for startups like hey,
we're going to be the next
[INAUDIBLE] of China, the next
Tesla Cars for like India and
things like that.
Those countries still do not
have the same problems or even
care about the same things that
a US or Western type of
citizen would care about?
NILOFER MERCHANT: Well, I think
one of things that you
guys often do, and I think I
just saw it got announced
today, is you announce
opportunities for people to
start creating value and
change the world
in their own way.
And you guys just announced
Google X--
what did you call it?
X vision?
AUDIENCE: Solve for X.
NILOFER MERCHANT: Solve
for X. Thank you.
It's figuring out how to use
openness as an asset so that
you're not even defining
what the
problem is or the solution.
And how do you build your entire
technology system so
that you don't have to own the
outcome of it but allowing
many, many voices to play,
bringing whatever unique
perspective they have from
around the world.
I told this story at lunch, but
I'll repeat it because I
just think it's a great story.
There was a program
called Foldit.
Do you know Foldit?
Protein folding crowd
sourced application.
And when they first started it,
they had this very strong
preconception of who would
end up contributing.
And so they're fundamental
thesis was well, we're really
like bright MIT people.
And we'll have other people,
but from other countries,
participate.
So we'll get the best of India,
and the best of China
to participate, and so on.
But in their head, the
preconception was it's going
to look a lot and feel a lot
like who they were but just in
another region.
And the person who ended up
becoming the best protein
folder in the world, which if
you know this, you actually
can accelerate science
research.
So it's incredibly important.
The best protein folder
in the world?
Anyone know the answer?
It was a woman.
An admin during the day,
a nurse by training in
Manchester.
Sort of the opposite of what
they were thinking.
But because the openness of the
architecture, instead of
holding on to the outcome, the
openness of the architecture
allowed a lot of difference to
show up in the system and
allow the very best qualified
person to win.
And that's actually, to me, the
fundamental twist in the
social era.
If before it was about picking,
and bedding, and
choosing, and building
an empire?
This is just the opposite, which
is how do I not pick?
How do I not bet?
How do I actually encourage
anyone anywhere to contribute?
It's not that everyone will
but that anyone can.
And then all of a sudden, you
open up a global economy.
AUDIENCE: Very interesting
talk.
It seems like the purpose area
is a problematic area in some
sense in that by defining
purpose, there's, almost like
marketing, you only have a
certain appetite for purpose.
So how does Kellogg's cereal,
alongside toothpaste,
alongside the wide kind
of [INAUDIBLE]
of products.
How do you establish purpose and
actually allow consumers
not to become fatigued?
NILOFER MERCHANT: I'm not sure
Kellogg's or a thing applies
to that just so.
But I think it's figuring out
what is in the commons that
are unsolved problems?
That's how I'm really starting
to think about purpose.
So for a minute, I think people
know how to get breakfast.
So for a moment, I'm going
to park that sucker.
Although healthy breakfast could
certainly own a category
because it's hard.
But it's figuring out what is
this thing in the commons
that's unseen, that if I step
out there, I can start to
figure out what are unsolved
things and then
how do we own it.
IBM did a couple years
ago when--
probably one of the best
companies that's done this--
is they had a--
what did they call it-- a brain
jam I think is what
their third term was for
it a couple years back.
And they said, we know we should
be doing more in the
green space.
We honestly don't know what.
That's exactly how
they said it.
We don't know what it is.
We don't know what it is
we could add value to.
We don't know who we
should work with.
Maybe you guys could come
help us shape that.
And that has become, that
genesis, now three or four
years later is contributing
about 5.5% of their gross
revenue in this notion of
Smarter Planet and a series of
product lines around it.
But what they did is they asked
people to actually just
come into the space with them
and said, anybody want to help
shape how IBM does more green.
So in that case, they didn't
own even what it is they
should do or how they should
deliver it, but they stepped
into the uncertainty
of the space.
And they could have
looked like fools.
They look back at that
like wow, that
could have gone badly.
But they just really did a
discernment process with other
people, with curiosity,
inviting people to
come play with them.
And I think that gives us a
genesis of even just saying
what is an unsolved problem, and
how you magnetically start
attracting people to come help
you even define that problem,
I think it's quite attractive.
AUDIENCE: As you're talking
about scale,
it reminds me of--
so I work on the Google
Product Forum.
So it's like our help forums
for Google products.
And the way that we've always
thought about improving that
product is how to scale it
better kind of in the same
sense of what TED is doing.
Like they want users to
generate the content.
We want users to be our helpers
instead of having
Google invest in one to one
support for our consumer
products, which is
not possible.
So one thing I wanted to ask
you about is how you create
purpose when your product is
already set, your mission is
already set.
How do you create a purpose
that's beneficial to the user,
also beneficial to Google out of
circumstances already kind
of created for you.
NILOFER MERCHANT: Why
don't you ask them?
AUDIENCE: Ask the user?
NILOFER MERCHANT:
Ask the user.
So here's the thing.
I think sometimes we want to
know the answer before we ask
the question kind of thing.
But in the case of Intuit--
I'll just use that as another
example-- they actually opened
up to their own accounting team,
all the people who use
their platform.
Is there any way you guys could
be more interactive that
we could help with?
And what it turns out is people
in Idaho really don't
understand the tax rules in
California and vice versa.
And they said, if you could just
let us have online form
to make sure nothing illegal
happens here and manage the
tension there so that crazy
stuff doesn't happen, you'd
actually have created
something incredibly
valuable for us.
And they solved that
problem themselves.
And then, the community
starts to step back.
And of course, then they also
take over answering the, what
I'll call, dumb questions
for a second.
They also take over answering
the dumb questions because
while I'm here, and I'm talking
to you about these
other harder problems, I'll
give a few minutes here.
The exchange starts to become
valuable because neither side
is depleted.
That's the very definition of
the social era is in the
exchange, neither side
is depleted.
So TED and TEDx both benefit.
There's something in
the common that
they're building together.
It's not an exchange where I
pay you or you pay me, and
then each one goes their own
separate ways, or I take
advantage of you.
The very definition of social
means you get to solve
something together.
So if you don't know the answer
to it, I think the
answer becomes how do you
ask the question well?
To say we'd love to think about
more ways for us to have
more scale, for us to step back
and maybe add more value
in the process.
What could that be?
And you may find no answers.
And you might look silly
for a few minutes.
But that's probably the worst
thing that's going to happen.
But what might happen are
some creative answers.
So it starts reformulating
the question.
AUDIENCE: In the questions where
we're crowd sourcing,
does it go to the
other extreme?
Like you buy something from
Amazon, now they're completely
peppering you for reviews on
every item that you've bought.
And it's like listening
to NPR.
There are those weeks where you
have to listen, even if
you've contributed and
you invest in it.
When does it become too much
where you're starting to crowd
source, and everybody's
doing the same thing?
And you're hitting the same
audience multiple times.
NILOFER MERCHANT: So
this whole thing is
becoming about attention.
Attention is the currency
of the social era.
The more you can get someone
a higher return for their
currency of attention, they're
going to gravitate to you.
I think Facebook, for example,
is actually coming
at too high a cost.
I think it's actually
at a tipping
point in one direction.
I think it's really
about currency.
So Amazon doing that behavior
makes me want to
shop less at Amazon.
And I'm like one of their
big customers.
I'm just really clear
about that.
And they're just driving me so
nuts that I'm actually sitting
here thinking, OK, now you've
made it where I no longer want
to interact with you because
there's no preference setting
I could do to turn that
little sucker off.
They're making it possible
for someone else
to enter the space.
Think about what you're doing
is managing attention.
And then think about in
that exchange, are
you making it equal?
That exchange about getting a
ping back is helping Amazon.
It's not helping me.
And they've now created a
cost for me to interact.
They've changed the
currency exchange.
So I think that becomes a really
interesting metric as
we go forward, how
to look at that.
Did I answer your question?
OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So this strategy of
going to the user community,
and asking for help, and
collaboratively solving
problems, does that strategy
still work when the problem
you're trying to solve is bad
actors in the community?
NILOFER MERCHANT: So does it
solve the problem when there's
bad actors?
I think it does.
And so I happen to have a
Harvard Magazine piece coming
out on this TED debacle,
which was just brutal.
I'm not sure how much-- you were
nodding your head when I
talked about Reddit.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NILOFER MERCHANT:
Did you see it?
AUDIENCE: I went to a bad
TED a couple years ago.
[INAUDIBLE].
NILOFER MERCHANT: Yeah.
So one of the things that they
actually just said in the
interview process--
because I was trying to get this
article to be really as
tight as possible.
And so I asked them, how do
you think about this?
How do you think about the
management part of this?
And they said, listen.
It's not us managing.
It's not me going out there
and saying, no, no, no.
It's figuring out how to raise
the bar and standard where
they tell each other no.
You should not have, you should
not be a TEDx licensee.
Not that person.
And it finds a way
to filter out.
It's a very similar system to
what eBay created when the
first transactions happened.
How do you build more trust in
the system because social era
is all about relationships.
So relationships are the way
in which we're going to
measure it.
Trust is an outcome
of a relationship.
How do you build up trust?
So they've got to figure out how
to build more metrics into
the system, feedback loop back
to TED saying these people did
not put on a good event, et
cetera so the license does not
get renewed.
So the system becomes
reinforcing.
And peer reviews end up
really shaping that.
So there are ways to do it.
But they have to think about
it not as them telling, or
them directing, or them even
being in charge because the
way to do a community is to
have a community police.
AUDIENCE: OK, so you're not
saying that in the face of a
lot of bad actors, you
still need the
gatekeeper to take a role.
You're saying that's
still a solvable
problem with the community.
NILOFER MERCHANT: Mostly.
And then I think as it bubbles
up-- like the guy who did the
vortex mathematics talk, which
is the one I kind of mentioned
around the Quora.
It's a crazy talk.
If you can actually still find
it somewhere online, it's
really funny to watch because
the guy's just doing buzzword
bingo as fast as he
possibly can.
It's a hilarious talk in a
certain way because you're
like what's he doing?
So my opening line of my "Havard
Magazine" article is
what fucking bullshit because
I'm quoting the professor
who's like commenting
on the talk.
So I feel pretty good that I
managed to start a "Havard
Magazine" article with what
fucking bullshit.
Try sneaking that in.
But what that ends up
becoming is peer
review raises an issue.
And then of course, there's
a judgment call.
So it never eliminates the role
of the central body if
you still want to manage that.
But you get like 99% of
it to happen out here.
And you want accountability
because this is
all about an exchange.
So you can't sort of hold onto
the accountability and expect
people to feel ownership.
It works inside an
organization.
It works external.
The more you give people power,
the more they end up
creating and bring their
full selves to work.
So you want everything
like that.
You want to figure out how do I
assign this thing that might
be in my head as far away from
me as possible so the thing
that really matters is managed,
and everything else
can be their own source
of creativity.
Did I answer the question?
PRESENTER: Well, thank you so
much, Nilofer, for coming in.
It's been a really
interesting chat.
And we're going to post this
talk online as well on the
Authors at Channel.
So thanks everyone for coming
and dialing in.